[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليلى الاختيار استهلها بابرز
العناوين
بمستقبل الدعم الغربي لكياف
[تصفيق]
اشتباكات متقطعه تخترق الهدوء الحذر في
السودان والجيش والدعم السريع يؤكدان
التزامهما بالهدنه المعلنه
اللاجئون السوريون ورقه لاستماله الاصوات
في جوله الحسم بالانتخابات التركيه بين
اردوغان وكليتش
يؤكد عدم التوصل لحل حتى الان عبيد
المتفائل بانقاذ اقتصادي بلاده
[موسيقى]
لم يكن هنالك شيء اسمه اوكرانيا في
التاريخ بهذه الجمله مسح الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين اوكرانيا من خارطه التاريخ
قائلا انه قبل انشاء جمهوريه اوكرانيا لم
يكن هنالك دوله اسمها اوكرانيا في تاريخ
البشريه وعرض بوتين خلال اجتماع مع
المحكمه الدستوريه الروسيه تبرير قوله
بدوره اعاد الرئيس الروسي السابق ونائب
رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي حاليا ديمتري
اعاده احتمال حرب نوويه قائلا انه كلما
زاد عدد الاسلحه التي يتم توفيرها الكياف
كان العالم في وضع اكثر خطوره وزاد احتمال
تحقيق سيناريو نهايه العالم النوويه
اذا مشاهدينا ميدانيا تطور لافت ومقلق
بالنسبه لموسكو حيث اعلن المتحدث باسم
الكريم
بان مجموعه تخريبيه دخلت منطقه بلغورد
الروسيه على الحدود الاوكرانيه الروسيه
واعتبر ان الهجوم يهدف الى تحويل الانتباه
عن احتلال اوكرانيا وايضا
كما نشاهد هنا على هذه الخارطه
هذه هي المنطقه التي اتحدث عنها اذا بهذه
بالعوده الى هذه النقطه
اذا هذه
المحاوله او الاختراق يعتبر تطور لافت
يعني مساق الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه حيث
اضاف بسكوب بان وزاره الدفاع وجهاز الامن
الفيدرالي وحرس الحدود يتخذون كل التدابير
الضروريه للقضاء على المخربين هنا
مشاهدينا بحسب المعلومات الاوليه فان
المسؤولين عن الحادث ينتمون لجماعات قوميه
روسيه تقاتل في اوكرانيا هما فيلق الحريه
الروسي وفيلق المتطوعين الروسي هنا ايضا
للتذكير بان هذه الجماعات هي جماعات قوميه
متطرفه بحسب طبعا روسيا سلط الضوء عليها
بدايه الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه تطم تضم
طبعا متطوعين كانوا يقاتلون الى جانب
الجيش الاوكراني في بخموت وقتلوا بشراسه
وينتشرون طبعا في دومباس وهم اليوم بحسب
القوات الروسيه مسؤولين عن هذا الهجوم في
مدينه بلغرت
[موسيقى]
بين هذه الصور وهذه تحول جديد في الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه وتقاذف بالاتهامات بين
كييف وموسكو اتهامات بحقيقه واحده حتى
اللحظه حقيقه تقول ان المعركه عبرت الحدود
الاوكرانيه بالقرود تحت النار
بعمق ثمانيه كيلو مترات داخل الاراضي
الروسيه تتعرض مدينه بيلجرود لهجمات قيل
انها اوكرانيه الهجوم وفقا للكرملين بدا
بطائرات مسيره تبعه اقتحام قوه عسكريه
قالت انهم مجموعه من المخربين امر دفع
السلطات لاجلاء المدنيين من تسع قرى
حدوديه واعلان نظام مكافحه الارهاب
في اول تعليق روسي على التطورات الجديده
اتهم الكريم بالوقوف وراء الهجوم بهدف
تحويل الانتباه عن باخموت اتهام رفضته
كييف ونفت علاقتها بالهجوم وفقا
للاستخبارات الاوكرانيه فان الهجوم نفذته
مجموعتان روسيتان معارضتان الاولى تسمى
فيلق حريه روسيا والثانيه فيلق المتطوعين
الروس وكلا المجموعتين تتالفان من مواطنين
روس اذ اعلنت احدى المجموعتين تحرير بلده
كوزينكا الحدوديه مع ان الهجوم ليس الاول
على الاراضي الروسيه منذ بدء الحرب في
اوكرانيا وكان قد سبقه هجوم على الكرمله
نفسه الا انه الاول الاقتحام وتوغل عسكري
داخل روسيا هجوم قد يفتح ابوابا جديده من
الحرب وتطوراتها
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من موسكو عبد الجواد
رشد مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد يعني الوضع
امنيا بالمنطقه الحدوديه نتحدث عن بيل
جوردن يعني هذا الخرق الذي يعتبر
مختلف من نوعه منذ بدايه الحرب حتى اليوم
نتحدث عن دخول يعني بري ليس فقط عن
محاولات اختراق امنيه الاجواء من هناك لو
سمحت
مساء الخير ليالي نعم بالفعل يعني هجوم
بيل جرادي يعيد للاذهان هجوم بريانس قبل
نحو اشهر من الان نعم هو الهجوم الاعنف
خلال الصراع الاوكراني الروسي على الاراضي
الروسيه قرابه 80 جنديا دخلوا من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه نحو مقاطعه
دخلوا من محاور ثلاثه حسب الروايه الروسيه
عبر الغابات كانت معهم تسعه اليات منها
خمسه خمسه ثقيله هذا الهجوم طبعا ليال ادى
الى مقتل شخص واصابه ثلاثه عشر اخرين
جميعهم حسب روايه موسكو يعني في المشافي
الان ينالون ما يحتاجونه من امور العلاج
ليالي يعني ليست هي الهجمات الاولى على
بيلغراد لكنها الاعنف تلك المنطقه تشهد
الان حسب التقارير الوارده من هناك سقوط
العديد من العبوات الناسفه التي تقوم
بايصالها الى هناك مسيرات هذه العبوات
طبعا الامس وليله قبل امس سقطت على مباني
اداريه في المدينه البعض منها يتبع يعني
مراكز امنيه تعمل في بيليقا طبعا تم اجراء
عدد كبير من السكان اليوم رسميا تم الحديث
عن اجلاء اكثر من 100 شخص من مناطق حدوديه
اما القرى المحازيه للاراضي الاوكرانيه في
عمليه الاجلاء من هناك هي كبيره تم
الاعلان يوم امس عن قانون مكافحه الارهاب
لكن طبعا بعد عوده الامور الى وضعها
الطبيعي اليوم عاده طبعا سلطات بيلغراد
والغت هذا القانون نلاحظ العيال بان
المتريميدف يعود بالتلويح بسلاحه النووي
من جديد طبعا ويحمل ما حدث في بيل جراد
الليكيف ويحمل يعني واشنطن ولندن والاتحاد
الاوروبي المسؤوليه الكبرى بهذا الموضوع
هو يتحدث عن ان الضخ السلاح الى كييف
سيطيل عمر الازمه
وسيسرع من الصراع النووي لذلك هو تصعيد
كبير لم تشهده المنطقه منذ قبل الشريط
الحدودي الان مشتعل نوعا ما لكن موسكو حتى
هذه اللحظه تطمئن بما يخص الوضع الامني في
بلغراد تفضلي عبد الجواد يعني ايضا من
الملفت وليس ملفت هو متوقع ان تكون
المجموعه المسؤوله عن هذا الهجوم هي
مجموعه قوميه من الروس الذين انضموا
بالقتال لجانب القوات الاوكرانيه نظرا ان
الولايات المتحده لا تدعم طبعا اي تدخل
مباشر اوكرانيا داخل روسيا هل هناك اي
تدابير امنيه غير موضوع الغاء يعني عمليات
الغاء او حتى يعني نقل المواطنين من على
الحدود وهل هناك توقعات بهجوم جديد من قبل
هذه المجموعات خصوصا ان لا هناك يعني
معلومات مفصله حوله
كما هو ملاحظه من مقاطع الفيديو التي يتم
نشرها الان من تلك المناطق ليال ومن
التقارير الرسميه وغير الرسميه التي تنشر
على تيليجرام بان الكثير من المعدات
العسكريه اصبحت تظهر بشكل واضح في مقاطعه
بيلغراد خاصه في المناطق الغربيه المحازيه
للاراضي الاوكرانيه طبعا عمليه التدقيق
باوراق كافه المواطنين اصبحت تظهر بشكل
واسع كانت حكومه بيليج قد اعلنت عن هذا
الشيء يوم امس لكنها اليوم خففت من حده
هذه التصريحات لكن طبعا تعليقات المواطنين
على تيليجرام وعلى الكثير من مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي تتحدث عن قيام الجهات
المختصه في تلك المناطق بالتدقيق باوراق
المواطنين بتفتيش السيارات باقامه حواجز
وغير ذلك مما يخص الامور الامنيه لذلك
طبعا الوضع في تلك المناطق قراءه الكثير
من المحللين السياسيين في البلاد هو ذاهب
نحو الاسوا وهذه هي بدايه الحرب بالنسبه
لهم حسب روايتهم لذلك طبعا هي الضربات
الاعنف داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه نلاحظ
داخل الاراضي الروسيه نلاحظ بان اخبار
المسيرات يعني تنشط عند المساء بعد غياب
الشمس بعد قطع الكهرباء عن الكثير من
المناطق وحينها طبعا تظهر الاخبار
والتقارير الوارده من هناك تتحدث عن
مسيرات مختلفه تطال تلك المنطقه شكرا لك
عبد الجواد الرشد حدثنا من موسكو
كشفت صور جويه تم التقاطها لمدينه بخموت
حجم الدمار الذي طال المدينه التي شهدت
معارك ضاريه خلال اشهر فلنتابع
[موسيقى]
بينما تدخل اوكرانيا مرحله محوريه في
حربها مع روسيا تتطلع الولايات المتحده
والناتو الى كيفيه تحويل البلاد الى حصن
ضد روسيا وذلك عبر انشاء نظام امني مماثل
لاسرائيل وفق ما كشفته هنا
الامريكيه الاتفاق الامني سيعطي الاولويه
لنقل الاسلحه والتكنولوجيا المتطوره الى
اوكرانيا وسيرتبط هذا الاتفاق الامني ايضا
بعمليه انضمام في المستقبل طبعا ولكن من
دون ان يقحم الناتو في صراع مباشر مع
موسكو وهنا اكدت الصحيفه على لسان الرئيس
البولندي ان نقاش مستمر حول هذا الموضوع
بموافقه القاده الغربيون بمن فيهم الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن
[موسيقى]
قال مسؤول السياسه وشؤون الخارجيه للاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بورال ان هدف الاتحاد هو
توفير مليون قذيفه مدفعه لاوكرانيا عبر
مقاربه ثلاثيه
كما تعلمون في العشرين من مارس قررنا
تخصيص ملياري يورو لتزويد الذخيره
للمدفعيه الاوكرانيه
الهدف هو توفير مليون قذيفه مدفعيه خلال
الاثني عشر شهرا قادمه وسيكون نهجا ثلاثيا
المسارات اولا سنطلب من الدول الاعضاء
توفير الذخيره من مخزونها حتى لا ننتظر
انتاج المزيد من الذخائر لكننا سنستفيد من
الذخيره الموجوده واحدث الارقام افضل
بكثير مما كان لدينا قبل عشره ايام فقط
لانني استطيع ان اعلن اليوم انه بفضل هذا
المسار قدمت الدول الاعضاء 220 الف ذخيره
مدفعيه من عيارات مختلفه وتم توفير 1300
صاروخ
يه
بولندا تتقدم نحو تحقيق حلمها في انشاء
امبراطوريتها الخاصه في اوروبا وهذا الامر
يهدد امن روسيا وفق ما كشفت هنا صحيفه
روسيه التي قالت بان الامبراطوريه
البولنديه حلم قديم تطمح اليه وارسو وتسعى
الى تنفيذه من خلال مبادره البحار الثلاثه
التي تضم اثني عشر دوله من شرق اوروبا اما
البحار ثلاثه التي تشكل الشرايين الحيويه
لاوروبا والامبراطوريه البولنديه المزمعه
فهي كما نشاهد هنا بحر البلطيق البحر
الادرياتيكي والبحر الاسود حول بولندا
والتي تمثل
28% من اراضي الاتحاد الاوروبي واثنين
وعشرين بالمئه من حجم سكانها لكنها تسهم
بعشره بالمئه فقط من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي لهذه المنطقه والهدف الرئيسي
لمبادره البحار الثلاثه هو الاقتصاد
اوروبا الشرقيه والوسطى بمستوى اقتصاد
اوروبا الغربيه من خلال تطوير البنيه
التحتيه المشتركه للدول لتعزيز الروابط
الوثيقه بينهما اما مشاهدينا الاهداف
الاخرى التي تتعلق مباشره بالمشروع او ما
يعرف بالمشروع الجيوسي هنا من خلال ربط
شمال اوروبا بجنوبها من اجل هزم العدو اي
روسيا في مجال امدادات الطاقه توضح هنا
الصحيفه الروسيه هدف المشروع ايضا انشاء
تدريجي لكتله عسكريه اقتصاديه لبلدان
اوروبا الشرقيه تحديدا حول بولندا ولتقليظ
حجم التبعيه لروسيا وتقويض امن روسيا
بموافقه واشراف الجانب الامريكي التي اذن
طبعا ليوارسو بيتم تمثيل المصالح
الامريكيه في المنطقه وهذا طبعا كل هذا
التحليل بحسب الصحيفه الروسيه
[موسيقى]
الى الملف السوداني والصراع العسكري هناك
حيث خروقات واطلاق نار وقصف مدفعي جميعها
احداث تهدد الهدنه في البلاد بعد ساعات
فقط من دخولها حيز التنفيذ فقد افاد مراسل
العربيه بوقوع اشتباكات بالاسلحه الخفيه
هو الخفيفه بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع في ام درمان فيما تحدثت وسائل
الاعلام عن سماع اصوات مواجهات وغارات
جويه جنوب العاصمه وفي الضواحي الشماليه
الشرقيه بالاضافه الى وقاع اشتباكات في
شارع الغابه وسط الخرطوم
من جهته رحب مجلس الوزراء السعودي بتوقيع
طرفي النزاع في السودان على اتفاق وقف
اطلاق النار القصيره الامد كما اعرب مجلس
الوزراء السعودي برئاسه الملك سلمان عن
اماله في ان تركز المحادثات المحادثات
السودانيه على وقف دائم للاعمال العدائيه
وتفعيل العمليه السياسيه
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني بلينك كان
قد دعى الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
الى الالتزام بالهدنه المتفق
ان العنف الذي ارتكبه طرف الصراع ماساوي
ومدمر وبلا معنى مشيرا الى ان العالم يصر
على حل تفوضي
ان العنف الذي ارتكبته القوات المسلحه
السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع الشهر
الماضي كان ماساويا وبلا معنى ومدمرا لقد
اتحد العالم كله في الدعوه لانهاء هذا
الصراع والاصرار على حل تفوضي ان الاتفاق
بين القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم
السريع على هذه الاتفاقيه لوقف اطلاق
النار لمده قصيره كان نتيجه الدبلوماسيه
المكثفه وشراكه الوثيقه بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والولايات المتحده
التاسع مستمره فيها بعد
قليل المحكمه البريطانيه ترفض منح الامير
هاري حمايه امنيه داخل المملكه المتحده
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد انقلاب تركي سوري على
اجتماع موسكو بعد تصريحات الرئيس التركي
اردوغان التي اعتبرت ان سحب الجيش التركي
من شمال سوريا سيشكل ضعفا امنيا لبلاده
وجانب السوري يشدد على لسان وزير الخارجيه
السوري فيصل المقداد ان وجود القوات
التركيه والمجموعات المسلحه في شمال غربي
سوريا يجب ان ينتهي وانا لقاء الرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد مع اردوغان برهوم بذلك
التصعيد التركي السوري جاء بعد اجتماع
موسكو الاخير واعتبره البعض تعويما
دبلوماسيا لاردوغان قبيل انتخابات الرئاسه
في جولتها الاولى ولاجل ذلك لم يصمت كثيرا
وعادت تصعيد بين الطرفين الى الواجهه من
جديد وبالعناوين نفسها ما يضع اعلان موسكو
بمهب الريح وفق الخبراء
اذا تحولت قضيه اللاجئين السوريين الى ملف
رئيسيه في حملات الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه في تركيا واليوم هي العنوان
الابرز لاستقطاب الناخبين للجوله الثانيه
في 28 من مايو والتي اكد فيها اوغاند زعمه
لاردوغان بعدما كان مشترطا طرد اللاجئين
السوريين مقابل هذا الدعم اما الرئيس
التركي اردوغان فنفى رضوخه لشروط
لكنه في الوقت ذاته اكد بانه يعد خطه
لعوده مليون لاجئ سوري الى بلادهم بعد
دراسه للتوقيت المناسب لضمان عودتهم كلام
اردوغان مشاهدينا جاء رد مباشر على منافسه
في انتخابات الرئاسه كمال كلتش دار اوغلو
بشان ياتي حل قضيه عوده اللاجئين السوريين
في غضون سنتين في حال تم انتخابه
لتركيا وتشديد الاجراءات لمكافحه الهجره
غير الشرعيه السلطات التركيه ذكرت في
يناير الماضي بان عدد اللاجئين السوريين
الموجودين في تركيا يبلغ ثلاثه فاصله خمسه
مليون شخص وخلال عام 2022 عاد الى سوريا
نحو 59 الف لاجئ من اصل كل هذا العدد
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من اسطنبول جواد جوك
المحلل السياسي استاذ جواد يعني من
الناحيه العمليه ساترك موضوع الخطاب ساعود
اليه بعد قليل ولكن من الناحيه العمليه
الاتفاق الذي حصل بين اوغان وبين اردوغان
سيكون يعني بنهايه نفوس سياسي
لطبعا اوجان داخل حكومه اردوغان بالمرحله
المقبله هذا النفوس هل سيفرض على اردوغان
تغيير ولو يعني ليس كامل بسياسته باعاده
اللاجئين الى سوريا
تحيه لمشاهدين الكرام لا اتوقع ذلك اذا
فاز الرئيس اردوغان في الجوله الثانيه
الامور كلها بيده اذا يريد ترحيل اللاجئين
يرحلهم اذا يريد بقائهم يبقون على راحتهم
يعني لا يقدر احد ان يجبر الرئيس اردوغان
لارسال اللاجئين او لبقائهم هنا في تركيا
يعني مشكله اللاجئين مشكله كبيره جدا
وبصراحه لا تنحل بالسهوله يعني ولو انه
يقول بعد سنه خلال سنه سوف نرحل مليون
لاجئ الى شمالي سوريا كيف تقدر ترسله وانت
لا تريد سحب القوات التركيه لا تؤمن
شماليه سوريا لا عوده العلاقات مع نظام
بشار الاسد مشاكل كبيره جدا انا اقول
بصراحه يعني اهم القضيه هذه القضيه قضيه
اللاجئين
من لابد ان يكون هناك تعاظم مع اشقاءنا
العربي بشكل عام هناك المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لابد ان نستشير معهم مع الامارات
مع مصر ثم ان نجتمع معهم لنجد حلا وسطيا
لترحيل اللاجئين لعوده اللاجئين
الحكومه التركيه لا زالت بعيدا يعني سياسه
اردوغان بموضوع اعاده اللاجئين طبعا هي
مختلفه تماما عن سياسه مرشح المعارضه ولكن
هذه الانتخابات اذا ما اثبتت اثبتت بان
الصوت القومي او الجنوح نحو القوميه
التركيه نحو الهويه والتشدد بموضوع الهويه
اصبح امر واقع هل يمكن لاردوغان حفاظا على
المستقبل السياسي لحزبه ولكل يعني وجوده
ان يسمح له ان يكون يعني بنفس النفس
يتعاطى بموضوع اللاجئين بالمرحله المقبله
نحن كلنا نعرف ان الحال لا يمشي بهذا
الشكل يعني خاصه ليست فقط قضيه السوريين
عشرات الالاف عبر الحدود الايرانيه جاؤوا
افغانيون وباكستانيون ولازال ياتون هؤلاء
بشكل غريب هذا يخفف البلد يعني تغيير
ديبوغرافي وغير ذلك لكن بصراحه
الرئيس اردوغان سياسته سوف تستمر ببقاء
السوريين خاصه السوريون الموجودون هنا
يدعمون بقاء
اردوغان الذين
يصابطون لصالح اردوغان مئه بالمئه صحيح
لكن بشكل عام هناك الرده فعل رده فعل من
قبل الشارع التركي يزداد القوميه هذا الذي
يخالفنا اخواننا السوريون هؤلاء نشاطات
جدا في التجاره وفي العمل وفي تطبيق
انفسهم مع الشعب التركي مع وطننا لا باس
به يمشي يمشون بقوه لكن لا يستمر بهذا
الشكل والبلد يعني نرى انه ازدياد يعني
تشدد قوميا نخاف من
يعني
الاشتباكات بين
الشعب التركي وبين الاخوان من السوريين
المشكله مشكله كبيره نخاف ان تخرج القضيه
من السيطره
ومع ازدياد حتى الرئيس اردوغان يعني يشارك
في ازدياد القوميه في خطابات قوميه ازدادت
مسلسلات التركيه العثمانيه يعني هذا كله
تؤثر على تؤثر سلبيا في قضيه القوميه
والكراهيه مع الاسف الشديد لا نجد حلا له
ولا نرى ضوءا في اخر النفقه نحن اليوم
امام معادله زياده الازمه الاقتصاديه
زياده الانهيار الاقتصادي
ويقابلها زياده القوميه والتمسك يعني بكل
ما هو داخله طبعا مربوطه ببعض ولا يمكن
فصل عن بعضها امام هذين يعني المرتكزين
الموجودين اليوم بالداخل التركي لا يمكن
لاردوغان في حال فوزه بالجوله الثانيه ان
يكون تعاطيه بملف النازحين مشابه لما قبل
الانتخابات
نعم بالنتيجه
ملف الاقتصادي ملف غريب جدا انظروا في سنه
2002 عندما جاء الرايس اردوغان الى الحكم
كان ديوننا ديون البلد الى الخارج
158 مليار دولار الان الان في هذه السنه
اكثر من 450 مليار دولار يعني 58 حكومه
قاموا يعني جاءوا بنا ديون كهديه الى
الشعب التركي 150 مليار الان 450 مليار
دولار وكل الخبراء هنا يؤكدون ان الامور
سوف تكون قد يخرج عن السيطره لانه 200
مليار دولار انتهت وقتها ولابد ان ندفع في
هذه السنه مشكله كبيره جدا طبعا يعني قضيه
اللاجئين يعني تاثيرها صغير جدا لان
الازمه ازمه كبيره ليست كارثه ليست اذنه
بل افلاس كما يقولون هذا الذي يخذف نا
جميعا وهناك اشاره في البنوك التركي ان
الازمه سوف تزال شكرا لك من اسطنبول جواد
جوكا المحلل السياسي
[موسيقى]
اكد رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي بان
بلاده في لحظه ما قد تطر لتدخل بسبب
التطورات الحاصله في ملف ايران النووي
الامر الذي قد يستدعي عملا اسرائيليا على
حد تعبيره خاصه وان ايران قطعت شوطا كبيرا
في تخصيب اليورانيوم وذلك في خضم تحذيرات
تل ابيب من نشاط طهران المزعزعه للاستقرار
الاقليمي والدولي وفق قولها
تقدمت ايران في برنامجها النووي في
السنوات الاخيره في تخسيب اليورانيوم اكثر
من اي وقت مضى نحن نراقب عن كثب ايضا
المجالات المتعلقه بالتطوير النووي وبدون
الخوض في التفاصيل ايضا بسبب الوقت ساقول
ان هناك تطورات سلبيه محتمله في الافق
ويمكن ان تؤدي الى اتخاذ اجراءات وهذا امر
مهم للغايه
[موسيقى]
تدرس مجموعه العمل المالي ادراج لبنان على
القائمه الرماديه اقتصاديا بسبب ممارسات
غير مرضيه خاصه فيما يتعلق بزياده في نشاط
غسيل الاموال وعدم الشفافيه في التعاملات
المصرفيه فلنتابع تفاصيل
لبنان الى المربع الرمادي
[موسيقى]
ضربه جديده للاغتصاد
مسوده لمجموعه العمل المالي تدرس ادراج
لبنان ضمن القائمه الرماديه
المسوده وصفت لبنان بالملتزم جزئيا فقط
بمكافحه غسل الاموال والشفافيه القانونيه
ادراج بمثابه لائحه اتهام ضد لبنان
قرار سيغلق ابواب التمويل الدولي مستقبلا
يقيد الاستثمارات والمعاملات المصرفيه
المساعي للوصول الى اتفاق مع الصندوق
الدولي لن تنجح قريبا
[موسيقى]
ارتفاع فاحش للتكاليف المعيشيه
اقتصاد والنهض سيسير بوتيره قد تكون ابطا
عالميا
قالت منظمه لرص عمليات الهجره في البحر
المتوسط انها تلقت نداء استغاثه من قاره
توقف محركه يحمل على متنه 500 لاجئ غير
شرعي ابحر من ليبيا محذره من ان القارب
يواجه خطر الغرق في وسط البحر بسبب تعطل
المحرك واضافت المنظمه عبر حسابها على
تويتر بانه تم ابلاغ السلطات مؤكده اهميه
سرعه بذل الجهود المطلوبه لانقاذ اللاجئين
[موسيقى]
قررت محكمه اسلام اباد تمديد كفاله رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران خان ضد
الاعتقال في عده قضايا تتعلق بالارهاب ومن
المقرر ايضا ان يمثل عمران وزوجته امام
فرع لمكتب المحاسبه الوطنيه في العاصمه
اسلام اباد حيث يواجهان تهمه فساد تتعلق
بما يعرف بقضيه وقف القادر والتي يتهم
فيها بالاستحواذ على اراض واموال بقيمات
190 مليون جنيه استرليني بطريقه غير شرعيه
عمران خان نافا كافه التهم ضده
ووصفها بالمسير
[موسيقى]
رفضت المحكمه العليا البريطانيه الطعن
الذي تقدم به المحامو الامير هاري حول
توفير حمايه شرطيه له خلال زيارته للمملكه
المتحده حتى في حال سداد تكاليف تلك
الحمايه من ماريا الخاص وقال قادم في لندن
ان الحكومه البريطانيه لم تتجاوز سلطاتها
عندما حرمته من توفير الحمايه له خلال
وجوده في المملكه المتحده وضحا انه لا
ينبغي السماح لضباط الشرطه بالعمل كحراس
شخصيين للاثرياء
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
بعد تعرضه للعنصريه الشرطه الاسبانيه
تتدخل لانصاف نجل النجم ريال مدريد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد استانف الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن محادثات مع الجمهوريين في
الكونجرس بهدف التوصل الى اتفاق يجنب
الولايات المتحده التخلف عن سداد مستحقات
ديونها وستحضرات وزاره الخزانه من نفاذ
اموال الخزينه العامه بعد الاول من يونيو
بايدن اعرب عن تفائله بالتواصل لحل ينقذ
اقتصاد بلادي وسمعته ادارته امام مكارسي
رئيس مجلس النواب فاكد عدم التوصل الى حل
حتى الان لكنه اشار الى امكانيه التواصل
لاحقا
[موسيقى]
الدوله الاقوى اقتصاديا في العالم هي
الولايات المتحده لكنها تتصدر ايضا قائمه
الدول صاحبه الدين الاكبر عالميا وهو رقم
اعتبر ضخما جدا الدين الامريكي مشاهدينا
يبلغ الان نحو
31.4 تريليون دولار وهذا الرقم يحصل لاول
مره في تاريخ الامريكي والاسباب كثيره
منها الوباء والحروب وفقا لخبراء الاقتصاد
ليس هذا فحسب بل هناك شكوك حول عجز
الولايات المتحده عن سداد هذا الدين قبل
الاول من يونيو من عام 2023 وهو الموعد
المقبل مع استمرار عدم توصل الكونجرس
لاتفاق حول رفع سقف الدين وبالتالي هذا
امر قد يعود بالكوارث على الاقتصاد وعلى
الولايات المتحده والاقتصاد العالمي برمته
لكن السؤال هنا ما هو سقف سقف الدين
مشاهدينا هو المبلغ الاجمالي للاموال التي
يحق للاداره الامريكيه والحكومه الامريكيه
تحديدا اقتراضا للوفاء بالتزاماتها
الماليه والحاليه مثل مدفوعات الضمان
الاجتماعي استرداد الضرائب وغيرها وعندما
يحدث فرق بين الدين الحكومي والانفاق
السنوي هنا يحدث ما يعرف اقتصاديا بالعجز
في الميزانيه وهنا ياتي السؤال الاهم ايضا
ماذا لو تخلفت الولايات المتحده عن سداد
الدين الذي يبلغ كما ذكرنا قبل قليل اكثر
من 31
تريليون دولار امريكي هنا يرى الخبراء بان
اخطر العواقب هو انهيار قيمه الدولار
المهيمن على حركه التجاره العالميه
فبالنسبه للشركات الامريكيه ان هيمنه
الدولار تعني انها لا تخضع لمخاطر سعر
الصرف مثل منافسيها الاجانب
عالميا فقد تجبر بعض الحكومات والشركات
على دفع فواتيرها
الدوليه طبعا بعملات اخرى ما قد يشكل خطرا
على استقرار الاسواق الماليه العالميه اما
هنا الرئيس الامريكي فقد المح للوجوه الى
التعديل الرابع عشر من الدستور لرفع دين
الحكومه سقف دين الحكومه الامريكيه لكنه
اشار الى ان الوقت لن يسعفه للقيام بذلك
[موسيقى]
مزيد من التفاصيل ينضم الينا من واشنطن
مراسل العربيه
لو سمحت يعني كل هذا النقاش الذي تحدثنا
عنه ما هو الجديد فيه هل نحن امام يعني
سقف انت تتحدث من ابنى امام مبنى وزاره
الخزانه على ما يبدو بالصوره فكل التفاصيل
معك تفضل
اولا وزيره الخزانه هذا الصباح ارسلت الى
الوزارات لتسال ما هي الفواتير التي لديها
اولويه وبالتالي تريد ان تعرف جانت ماذا
تدفع وماذا لا تدفع الامر الثاني المهم هو
ان مفوضين من البيت الابيض توجهوا هذا
الصباح الى مبنى الكونجرس الامريكي وهناك
جلسات من المفاوضات تعقد بينها ممثلي
الرئيس بايدن ورئيس مجلس النواب الجمهوري
مكارسين حتى الان لا احد يريد ان يقول ان
المفاوضات وصلت الى طريق مسدود الجميع
يريد ان يقول ان لديه النيه في الوصول الى
نتيجه ايجابيه ولكن حتى الان نحن لا نرى
نتيجه ايجابيه
الديمقراطيون متمسكون بموقف انه يجب ان
نتابع الانفاق المحفز
الجمهوريون يريدون القول انه يجب خفض
الانفاق ووقف العجز
ابيار امام يعني خفض الانفاق زياده
الضرائب تاثيرات ايضا على الفريق الحاكم
شعبيا النقاش سيذهب الى اين يعني بحسب كل
التقديرات هناك
اولا الامريكيون لا يريدون ازمه
الاقتصاديه او ماليه وبالتالي يريدون من
الطرفين ان يصلوا الى اتفاق مشكله الرئيس
الديمقراطي مع الحزب الديمقراطي هو انهم
لا يريدون تقديم تنازلات تخفف من زياده
مساعدات الحكومه للفقراء واحقاق العداله
الاجتماعيه وايضا قضايا تتعلق بالبيئه
الجمهوريون يرون ان الحكومه الامريكيه
تبذل المليارات وربما ايضا التريليونات
للمساعدات الاجتماعيه وهذه المساعدات لا
تعطي الناس الفرصه في العمل يريدون فرصه
في العمل الامريكيون بشكل عام ينتظرون انه
خلال الساعات الاخيره قبل ان يصلوا الى
الحائط المسدود سوف يصلون الى نتيجه
ايضا يعني من من ضمن كل ما يحكى عنه ايجاد
موارد جديده للخزينه لكي لا يذهبوا الى
ضرائب جديده بما ان الاقتصاد يعاني
موضوع الحدود موضوع الدعم الخارجي للحرب
في اوكرانيا كل هذا النقاش اي من هذه
النقاط ممكن ان نذهب الى يعني عمليه فعليه
شطبه او اضافتها
الرئيس الامريكي لديه حرج اساسي لانه ياتي
من حزب يعتبر انه يجب ان نجني المزيد من
المداخيل للخزانه الامريكيه من خلال فرض
الضرائب الجمهوريون يرفضون ذلك يجب ان
يجدوا طريقه ليقولوا ان هناك بعض الامور
الضروريه او غير التي لا نضطر بالفعل ان
يكون لدينا هذا البرنامج يجب ان يعطوا نوع
من الامل للناخبين لديهم من انهم قد وقفوا
عندما وقفهم الاساسيه ليس من الواضح في
هذه اللحظه ما هو الحل الذي سوف يتوصلون
اليه كان هناك نقاش جدي حول ارجاع الانفاق
الى مستويات العام 2022 او ابقائها عند
العام 2023 عندما تقر الميزانيه للعام 24
ولكن حتى الان ليس هناك اتفاق بين الاطراف
شكرا لك
على كل هذه المعطيات
نشرع البنتاجون صورا لقنبله ضخمه مصممه
للتواصل في عمق الارض وتدمير منشات تحت
الارض يمكن استخدامها لتخصيب اليورانيوم
ولكنه عاد وحذفها لانها كشفت تفاصيل حساسه
حول تركيبه السلاح الملقب بمخترق الخنادق
الضخمه وفقا لتقرير نشرته
[موسيقى]
نادوا عليه بالقرض ووجهوا له وابلا من
الانتقادات والشعارات العنصريه الاخرى هذا
ما حصل مع نجم ريال مدريد الاسباني
والمنتخب البرازيلي فينيوس فينيسيوس
جونيور خلال لقاء فريق مع فالنسيا فمع هذا
المشهد تعود العنصريه مره اخرى الى
الملاعب الاوروبيه لصيام الاسبانيه منها
ليضع الاتحاد الاسباني والرابطه هناك في
موقف حرج امام الاعلام الرياضي عشرات
سفارات الاستهجان العنصريه من جماهير
فالنسيا تعرضت فينيسيوس خلال اللقاء قبل
ان يطرد ويخرج من ملعب المسايه
نحن قلقون بشان ما حدث مع فينيسيوس ولقد
قيل الكثير حول هذا الامر يمكن ان تكون
فرصه رائعه لتحسين الامور بسرعه كبيره
فينيسيوس حزين بكل تاكيد لم يتدرب معنا
اليوم لكنه غاب بسبب بعض الاوجاع هذه
الممارسات يجب ان تتوقف لقد سئمنا من
الاهانه كل يوم هذا يحدث لتشافي في
برشلونه ويحدث لذيني ويحدث ايضا للعديد من
اللاعبين الاخرين مباراه كره القدم ليست
حرب بل هي مجرد رياضه لطالما كنا ندين
العنصريه وبعد الادانه نحتاج الى فعل لكن
لا احد يتصرف حيه لذلك فينيسيوس يحب نادي
ريال مدريد وهو يقاتل من اجله ويعرف جيدا
ان مستقبله هنا
هذا الموقف مشاهدينا فتح النار على اتحاد
الكره ورابطه الدوري في اسبانيا الرابطه
اعلنت التحقيق بالواقعه واتخاذ الاجراء
القانوني حاله تحديدها كجريمه كراهيه طبعا
واعلنت الشرطه الاسبانيه عن ايقاف ثلاثه
مشجعين يشبه بانهم وجهوا اساءات عنصريه
لمهاجم ريال مدريد كما اعتقلت الشرطه
الاسبانيه اربعه اشخاص على خلفيات التحقيق
في شنق دميه بقميص اللاعب البرازيلي في
شهر يناير الماضي فيمن هاله طبعا المواقف
الداعمه للاعب البرازيلي من مختلف انحاء
العالم انطلاقا من نجوم الكره ورئاسه
الفيفا مرورا بمشاهد الفن وصولا الى قاده
سياسيه
منسى في البدايه يجب الاعتراف بان لدينا
مشكله سلوك وتربيه وعنصريه في بلدنا طالما
ان هناك مشجعا واحدا او مجموعه من
المشجعين يهينون شخصا ما بسبب لون بشرته
فسنواجه مشكله خطيره تشوه صوره فريق
باكمله وجميع المشجعين والبلد ككل
فينيسيوس على حق بل واكثر مما نعتقد طالما
هناك فردا واحدا يهين اي شخص اسباب عنصريه
فنحن نعاني من مشكله حقيقيه هدفنا الان ان
يتمكن جميع لاعبي كره القدم من اللعب دون
ظهور او تكرار اي مشكله شبيهه بهذه
الاحداث
للحديث مشاهدينا عن هذه القضيه التي اثارت
جدل العالم طبعا ينضم الينا من قسم
الرياضه الزميل محمد القناص اهلا وسهلا
فيك محمد محمد يعني اليوم ما حصل مع
جونيور يعيد مجددا الى الواجهه موضوع
اجراءات الفيفا التي تعتبر برقراطيه بطيئه
بخصوص كل القضايا المتعلقه هناك وايضا
بروتوكول ايقاف التهم العنصريه او
النداءات والشتائم العنصريه كل هذا ماذا
يعني الان وماذا سيحصل بالمرحله المقبل
انه شق انساني اجتماعي وشق رياضي اولا على
الجانب الرياضي يبدو انه الهيئات ومؤسسات
الرياضيه لا زالت اقل بكثير او ابطا بكثير
من التحرك في مثل هذه الحالات شاهدناه هذه
الحالات تتكرر في كثير من الملاعب تحررت
تتكرر في كثير من اللاعبين يعني لو تحدثنا
عن لوكاكو في انت قبل اشهر قليله ايضا في
حالات مشابهه ايضا في ايطاليا وتحدثنا
ايضا في اسبانيا في كثير من الحالات
فينيسيوس جونيور شخصيا تعرضت في معظم
المباريات اللي لعبها خارج ارضه في الدوري
الاسباني كانت كثير من المباريات تتعرض
فيها الى مثل هذه الهتافات والى اكثر ايضا
من مثل هذه الهتافات في الفتره الماضيه
هذا على الجانب الرياضي لا زالت المؤسسات
الرياضيه ابطا من التحرك باتخاذ قرارات في
هذا الجانب الانساني على الجانب الاجتماعي
والانساني لا زالت الجماهير تستخدم مثل
هذه الهوتافات حتى تستفز الخصم تخرجه من
من
الاجواء
خلينا نذكر حادثه حصلت الموسم الماضي من
جمهور انتر ميلانو لما صار مثل هل هتافات
هذه على بعض اللاعبين فطلعت الرابطه قالت
انه احنا يعني ضد هذا الحركات صحيح
سويناها بس احنا ضده لانه عندنا لاعبين
الموضوع ياخذ اكبر من حجمه ما الى ذلك مثل
الروابط والمسائل او الجهات اللي تكون
ناشطه في الرياضه تكون ايضا عندها ترسبات
ثقافيه مجتمعيه محليه
يعني في مثل هذه الاحداث وبالتالي تكون
خلفيات اجتماعيه يعني نحن بالعاده كنا
نقول يعني بالمضمون الطبيعي للتاثير على
اداء اللاعبين اليوم اصبح يعني هو فيه
جانب عنصري كبير هذا الجانب العنصري كيف
ممكن ان يؤثر على يعني المنتخبات هناك
باسبانيا وعلى المرحله المقبله بالرياضه
هناك بالتاكيد لها تاثير كبير
ولها اثار سلبيه كبيره جدا يعني لما توصل
لمرحله انه الاتحاد الاسباني رابطه الدوله
الاسباني ما عندها الجراه لاتخاذ قرارات
حاده ايضا هذا الجزء ايضا يجب ان نلقي جزء
من الائمه ايضا حتى على على المسؤولين
الحكوميين ايضا امم تحركات جاده في مثل
هذه الحالات في كثير من الدول يكون في
تداخل من المدعي العام في اجراء تحقيقات
في ضبط المجرمين يعني شاهدنا اليوم طلعت
اخبار عن القبض على ثلاثه مشجعين كان لهم
تصرف عنصري في شهر يناير الماضي شهور يعني
فبالتالي يجب ان يكون في تحرك اكبر
هناك بروتوكول لموضوع الهتافات العنصريه
يتم ايقاف المباراه يتم لماذا لم يتم
اتباع او اتخاذ اي شيء من فيها من قبل
الحكم هو للاسف انه هذا الاشياء ما هي
بروتوكول مكتوب مثل قانون كره القدم ان
ركله الجزاء لما يحصل كذا
حريه تقدير الحاله للحكم وبالتالي بعض
الحكام ممكن انهم ما يتجراون يتخذون قرار
بمثل هذه القسوه على اعتبار انه وقت
المباراه في فلوس اندفعت في جمهور حذر في
وما الى ذلك وبالتالي يجب ايضا نتكلم على
الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم
وبالتالي ممكن قد يكون بالف انه في الاخير
هو جزء من المجتمع اللي حصلت في هذه
المشكله وبالتالي يجب اتحاد الدولي لكره
القدم الاتحاد الاوروبي لكره القدم
الاتحادات المحليه ايضا ان تصن قوانين
رادعه لمثل هذه الحالات اولا ايقاف
المباريات الغائها واحتساب الفريق خاسر
احنا شفنا حالات يعني مثلا لو تذكرنا حاله
مباراه انتر ميلان وميلان سنه 2005 بسبب
القاء بعض الالعاب الناريه في الملعب ثم
الغاء المباراه واعتبار احد الفريقين
فائزا وبالتالي يجب ان يكون في تدخل مثل
هذا الدراجات بعض الفرق يعني بالفترات
ايضا نرجع نقول حتى الجراه في اتخاذ
قرارات صارمه مش موجود احيانا يتم اتخاذ
قرار ثم يتم التراجعه ولكن المحزن هو
الموضوع العنصري الذي غير مقبل شكرا لك
محمد القناص الزميل من قسم الرياضه على
وجودك معنا
[موسيقى]
الثبات المتسلق ان بالي كاميريتا شيربا
بان الانسان باستطاعاته ان يتفوق حتى على
نفسه حيث تمكن هذا الرجل الخمسيني الملقب
برجل ايفرست من تحطيم الرقم القياسي للمره
الثامنه والعشرين معتاليا قمه سطح العالم
مرتين خلال اسبوع واحد
[موسيقى]
نشرت وكاله الفضاء الامريكيه ناسا صورا
جديده التقطتها احد مركباتها الجوال على
كوكب المريخ وبحسب ناسا فان هذه المنطقه
الظاهره في الصور هي رواسب رمليه لنهر
جافه قبل مليارات السنين كان موجودا على
الكوكب الاحمر يوما من الايام وتسعى
المركبه الجوال على العثور على اي شكل من
اشكال الحياه السابقه على المريخ
اقامت الملكه رانيا العبد الله عقيله
العهد الاردنيه حفل حنه في مضارب بني هاشم
بالعاصمه الاردنيه عمان بمناسبه قرب زفاف
ولي العهد الامير حسين بن عبد الله الثاني
والانسه والسيف المقرر في الاول من يونيون
المقبل وشارك في الحفل عدد من اميرات
العائله الملكيه وسيدات حضرنا من مختلف
محافظات البلاد وتخلل الحفل رسم بالحنه
وزفه للعروس واغاني واهازيج تراثيه وشعبيه
اردنيه وسعوديه
[موسيقى]
حصدت قناه العربيه الجائزه الثانيه
وثلاثين من بينها خمس جوائز من الفئه
الذهبيه من جوائز تعنى بتكريم التميز في
مجال التلفزيون والفيديو المزيد في
التفاصيل والتفاصيل في تقرير التاليه
38 جائزه نصيب قناه العربيه من جوائز تالي
العالميه في نسختها الرابعه والاربعين
الجائزه التي تنظم سنويا في الولايات
المتحده تقدم لارفع الانتاجات التلفزيونيه
وتقدم في فئات ثلاث
ذهبيه مفضيه وبرونسي
الجائزه تعد واحده من اهم الجوائز
المتخصصه في مجال تقييم محتوى الفيديو
والانتاج المرئي بمشاركه بئتي خبير من
مؤسسه اعلاميه وقنوات وشركات انتاج دوليه
ضمن الفئات التي ربحت جائزه التالي خمس
جوائز ذهبيه كانت من نصيبي ثلاثه برامج
وتغطيتين على الصعيد البرامج برنامج على
خط العرب ومهمه خاصه وعسكريتاريه اما على
الصعيد التغطيه فكانت من نصيب تغطيه
الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه وكذلك تقرير
نفذ بتقنيه الواقع الافتراضي من هو
جوائز التالي التي حازتها قناه العربيه
كانت ضمنها عشرون جائزه فضيه وثلاثه عشره
جائزه من الفئه البرونزيه
ذهبت لعدد من برامج العربيه وتغطياتها
الخاصه الاقتصاديه والسياسيه والوثائقيه
وبرامجها على مواقع التواصل والتصميم
الابداعي واستخدام الواقع المعزز
التاسعه مشاهدينا مع العناوين
يمحي اوكرانيا من التاريخ يربط موعد الحرب
النوويه بمستقبل الدعم الغربي الكياف
اشتباكات متقطعه تخترق الحدود والهدوء
الحذر في السودان والجيش والدعم السريع
يؤكدان التزامهما بالهدنه المعلنه
اللاجئون السوريون ورقه الاستماله الاصوات
في جوله حسب الانتخابات التركيه بين
اردوغان وكانت شتار اوغلو
وفي مباحثات سقف الدين الامريكي مكارسي
يؤكد عدم التوصل لحل حتى الان عبيد
المتفائل بانقاذ اقتصادي بلاده
التاسع انتهت مشاهدينا لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره كما كل ليله والان الى 360 وزميله
راويه مساء الخير راويه ماذا لديك مساء
الخير ليال سنتحدث عن حيثيات الهجوم على
بيل برود وايضا ملف الملف الانساني تحديدا
في السودان وكذلك الانتخابات التركيه تفضل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات